emotionale debatte im parlament der
staat habe die rechtsextremistische
gefahr zu lange unterschätzt sagt
bundespräsident bundestagspräsident
schäuble und fordert konsequente
durchsetzung des rechts weltweit immer
mehr corona fälle italien schließt alle
schulen kinos theater menschen sollen
mindestens ein meter abstand voneinander
halten
weltcupsieg für denise herrmann in
tschechien gewinnt die deutsche
biathletin wegen des virus vor leeren
rängen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers meine damen und herren
guten abend in allen heute um 7
christian und ich freuen uns dass sie
dabei sind absolut alles wichtige vom
sport etwas später von ihr erster
überblick über diesen nachrichten tag es
war ein bemerkenswerter tag im parlament
heute der deutsche bundestag debattiert
über den anschlag von hanau über
rechtsextreme gewalt und vor allem über
die frage welche konsequenzen daraus zu
ziehen sind ganz konkret und generell
für unsere gesellschaft und es fiel auf
wie wichtig es den rednern war die namen
der opfer nicht in vergessenheit geraten
zu lassen
die endgültigen werte des kia patsch
hansa-coach fördert in war kalorien welt
will you well seit und partie
es war eine scharf geführte debatte aber
auch einer mit vielen nachdenklichen
tönen winnie heescher hat die details
ein stiller moment das parlament gedenkt
der opfer von hanau solche
wahnsinnstaten geschehen nicht im
luftleeren raum sie wachsen in einem
vergifteten gesellschaftlichen klima in
denen das ressentiment gegenüber dem
fremden und abwegig die
verschwörungstheorien geschürt werden
bis minderheiten als bedrohung empfunden
und in sozialen medien heads akten oder
sogar morde von perversen
beifallsbekundungen begleitet werden
als zeichen der anteilnahme sind auch
der bundespräsident und vertreter der
muslime in deutschland gekommen
sie erleben eine debatte in der viele
redner namentlich benennen wen sie für
die färbung hier verantwortlich machen
die afd und vielleicht war es ein
einzeltäter aber wurde getragen von
einem system der hetze der erniedrigung
und der anleitung zu gewalt und diese
spur führt hinein in den bundestag und
die afg ist der komplize die mordtat von
hanau erschüttert und wühlt auf was auch
erschüttert ist die reflexhafte hetze
mit der hier opfer zur parteipolitischen
münze geschlagen werden
sie spannen ermordete menschen vor den
karren ihrer parteipolemik viel zuspruch
gibt es für abgeordnete die selbst
rassismus und morddrohungen erhalten
haben
besonders leise wird es als baa3 von
seinen eltern erzählt die im immer
geraten haben arzt zu werden was er als
kind hinterfragte dann haben meine
eltern geantwortet sollten sich die
politischen verhältnisse verhältnisse in
deutschland eines tages verändern wo du
musst an das land verlassen
als arzt wirst du überall im ausland
arbeiten können meine damen und herren
in den tagen von nsu kassel halle und
hanna mache ich mir aber oft gedanken
über den satz meiner eltern eine debatte
voller trauer scham mitunter wut und
viel gemeinsamkeit gegen rechts unser
nächstes thema ein wichtiges thema auch
heute die lage im kampf gegen des corona
virus während die gesundheitsbehörden
weltweit ihre bürger auf schwierige
wochen vorbereiten sind neue
einschneidende folgen in italien bereits
zu erleben
das land hat bereits 148 todesfälle zu
beklagen die zahl der infizierten dort
ist über nacht um knapp 800 gestiegen
seit heute sind alle schulen und
universitäten geschlossen viele kinos
und theater auch der tourismus liegt am
boden aus rom andreas postel wie stark
ein staat im krisenfall ins öffentliche
leben eingreifen kann lernen die schüler
am gymnasium giulio cesare in rom nicht
im unterricht sondern ab heute zu hause
per dekret sind landesweit alle schulen
kitas und universitäten bis mitte märz
geschlossen
fast zehn millionen schüler und
studenten sind davon betroffen und deren
eltern auch ich bin zurzeit
gezwungenermaßen zuhause für alle eltern
die arbeiten gehen müssen ist es
wesentlich schwieriger
vor allem viele kleinere kinder haben
hausaufgaben per e mail online
unterricht per smartphone italien
organisiert sich um die beschlossenen
maßnahmen der italienischen regierung
gehen weit geschlossen auch kinos und
theater öffentliche veranstaltungen
sport events messen und gottesdienste in
teilen des landes ab
es gehe darum zeit zu gewinnen die
ausbreitung des corona virus
auszubremsen premierminister giuseppe
konnte verteidigt sein dekret gegen
aufkommende kritik und kündigt ein
milliardenschweres hilfsprogramm an
wir haben 7,5 milliarden euro zur
verfügung gestellt
zur unterstützung von familien und
unternehmen von diesem ausnahmezustand
betroffen sind
dieser ist nicht nur ein
gesundheitlicher sondern auch ein
wirtschaftlicher notfall für den
tourismus deutet sich bereits ein
desaster an in rom fehlen spürbar die
gäste es ist ruhiger in der ewigen stadt
und es hängt sehr viel davon ab wie
lange die maßnahme andauern
bis auf weiteres ist italien ein land im
stillstand
alle schulen schließen in deutschland
sei das zurzeit nicht nötig sagen die
kultusminister die gesundheitsämter vor
ort entscheiden von fall zu fall wenn es
bestätigte corona fälle gibt deren zahl
ist bundesweit auf 400 gestiegen
lehrer und schulleiter sollen darauf
achten dass die hygieneempfehlungen
eingehalten werden
privathaushalte brauchen dabei keine
speziellen desinfektionsmittel sagen
experten
in apotheken sind die sowieso kaum noch
zu bekommen wie luton line aus zeugt
apothekerin helene rohr muss den
verunsicherten kunden viel erklären
dieser tage sie hat keine
desinfektionsmittel mehr auch keine in
der apotheke hergestellten der
wichtigste grundstoff ist nicht mehr
lieferbar das haben haben es der käufer
stattgefunden von wem weiß ich nicht man
braucht eigentlich im normalen alltag
kein desinfektionsmittel das sollte für
die kliniken und arztpraxen zur
verfügung gestellt wenn aber auch für
die kann ich keins mehr machen weil eben
der rohstoff fällt häufig vergeblich ihr
hinweis dass regelmäßiges händewaschen
mit seife im alltag doch viel wichtiger
sei die jagd auf desinfektionsmittel in
mancher klinik treibt sie mittlerweile
gefährliche blüten
wir beobachten mit sorge dass
desinfektionsmittel gestohlen wird wir
beobachten toilettenpapier diebstähle
die masken diebstähle und das macht uns
schon sorgen weil das eigentlich eine
situation ist in der der egoismus der
menschen im vordergrund tritt schon
jetzt drohen durch die diebstähle
regelrechte engpässe in krankenhäusern
der kampf gegen das virus ist auch eine
gegen verunsicherung und angst das
robert-koch-institut verbreitet heute
zuversicht die gute nachricht ist die
dass es wirklich zur zeit viele studien
gibt in china insbesondere sehr viele
studie gibt wo medikamente expo hotel
ausgetestet werden und wir sind
optimistisch dass in den nächsten wochen
soll die medikamente dann auch in
deutschland eingesetzt werden können
einen impfstoff gegen das corona virus
aber werde wohl erst nächstes jahr
einsatzfähig sein
das kroner virus und die folgen auf
heute de bekommen sie in unserem live
blog natürlich auch heute wichtige
informationen wie hat sich die zahl der
korona fälle weltweit entwickelt und
welche auswirkungen hat das virus auf
die wirtschaft so viel zunächst dazu die
immer schlimmer werdende situation in
der region idleb in syrien war heute das
thema beim treffen von zweien die
unmittelbar daran beteiligt sind
der russische präsident wladimir putin
empfing den türkischen präsidenten recep
tayyip erdogan in moskau nach sechs
stunden beratung haben sie sich auf eine
waffenruhe für die region im nordwesten
von syrien geeinigt
denn in idlib tobt ein erbitterter kampf
die region ist die letzte hochburg der
rebellen
die wir syrien mit russischer hilfe
vertreiben die rebellen werden von der
türkischen armee unterstützt für begann
berichtet dass die gespräche heute in
moskau keine einfachen werden würden war
klar dass sie so holprig beginnen nicht
wladimir putin fällt plötzlich auf dass
erdogans minister regeln noch auf eine
begrüßung wartet der türkische präsident
zieht nach auf freundliche gesten folgen
schmeichelnde worte in richtung des
gastgebers
die beziehungen der türkei und russland
befinden sich derzeit auf einem
höhepunkt das betrifft zum beispiel die
bereiche der verteidigung und des
handels show folgt die sich in idlib
allerdings befinden sich beide länder
gerade auf kollisionskurs
russland unterstützt die
regierungstruppen assad die im dezember
eine offensive auf die region begannen
die türkei wiederum unterstützt
verschiedene rebellen und schickte
zuletzt mehrere tausend eigene soldaten
umsatz vormarsch abzuwehren
eine direkte militärische konfrontation
ihrer länder wollen ankara moskau
vermeiden
in einem sechsstündigen gesprächs
marathon vereinbaren sie eine neue
waffenruhe für ihn
wir sind nicht immer mit unseren
türkischen partnern einverstanden wenn
es um die einschätzung der situation in
syrien geht doch durch das hohe niveau
unserer bilateralen beziehungen gelang
es in kritischen momenten immer eine
lösung zu finden muss durch die urvölker
schön es ist nicht das erste mal dass
die präsidentin der türkei und russland
sich vornehmen die kampfhandlungen aller
kriegsparteien in idlib zu beenden
ob es diesmal gelingt wird sich bald
zeigen ab mitternacht sollen die waffen
schweigen
neue waffenruhe hören wir also aus
moskau die eu-außenminister sitzen heute
den ganzen tag zusammen in kroatien in
zagreb dort ist stefan leifert für uns
was kann die eu denn tun damit die
menschen in und um idlib jetzt wirklich
tatsächlich frieden finden und
stabilität
dazu gibt es grundsätzlich zwei
möglichkeiten die eine möglichkeit ist
hochumstritten
die andere ist konsens konsens in der
europäischen union ist dass man jetzt
möglichst schnell im rahmen einer
waffenruhe den menschen in idlib helfen
und humanitäre hilfe anbieten will die
deutschen beispielsweise haben wir heute
schon 100 zusätzliche millionen in
aussicht gestellt die zweite möglichkeit
ist umstritten diese waffenruhe die
heute vereinbart worden es muss ja
irgendwie durchgesetzt werden
möglicherweise im rahmen einer
schutzzone oder flugverbotzone und da
teilt sich die eu jetzt in zwei lager
das eine lager ist der auffassung dass
die eu hier auch militärisch eine rolle
spielen sollte dazu gehört zum beispiel
die deutsche verteidigungsministerium
das andere lager ist der meinung dass
die eu nach wie vor dabei bleiben sollte
in diesem konflikt militärisch möglichst
keine rolle zu spielen
dazu gehört zum beispiel der deutsche
außenminister also nach der vereinbarung
von mosca von heute kommen auf die eu
eine reihe von unbequemen fragen zu eine
waffenruhe und viele fragen stefan
herzlichen dank seit zehn jahren wird
das ausmaß des missbrauchsskandals in
der katholischen kirche in deutschland
immer klarer
heute hat die bischofskonferenz gesagt
wie viel schmerzensgeld sie den opfern
zahlen will nämlich 5000 bis 50.000 euro
je nach fall die opferverbände sagen das
reicht bei weitem nicht eine unabhängige
expertengruppe hatte bis zu 400.000 euro
entschädigung für jedes opfer
vorgeschlagen die kirche zählt bisher
fast 3700 missbrauchsfälle
die dunkelziffer dürfte weit höher
liegen susanne gelhard
jahrelang wurden sie wie tausende andere
von katholischen priestern und
ordensleuten seelisch und sexuell
missbraucht und seit jahren warten sie
auf entschädigung
nun haben sich die katholischen bischöfe
auf regeln für alle deutschen bistümer
und möglichst auch für orden geeinigt
künftig soll einheitlich schneller und
auch mehr schmerzensgeld gezahlt werden
die zahlungen waren zu gering
jetzt orientieren wir uns an den
entscheidungen zu schmerzensgeld im
gerichtlichen bereich und haben zugesagt
dort auch in die oberen grenzen des
möglichen zu gehen
doch das reicht vielen missbrauchsopfer
nicht sie fordern eine entschädigung von
bis zu 400.000 euro pro person
das hatte eine kommission unter
mitarbeit von betroffenen den bischöfen
kürzlich vorgeschlagen
es muss eine entschädigung geben die die
folgen in der biografie und im leben der
betroffenen angemessen versucht
auszugleichen
eine anerkennung von wegen es ist was
schlimmes passiert aber wir sind ja
nicht gewesen die täter waren es das
kann es nicht sein
noch liegen die vorstellungen der
bischöfe und die erwartungen der
missbrauchsopfer weit auseinander
man will bis herbst jetzt konkrete
maßnahmen dann auch wirklich durchführen
können
ich bin da ein bisschen skeptisch ob die
bischöfe wirklich diesen zeitplan werden
einhalten können die betroffenen
jedenfalls müssen weiter warten
in würzburg steht ein logopäde vor
gericht wegen des sexuellen missbrauchs
von sieben kleinen jungen über jahre
hinweg
zum prozessauftakt legte der mann ein
geständnis ab laut staatsanwaltschaft
hat er die teils schwer behinderten
kinder in zwei kitas und in seinen
praxen missbraucht manche der opfer
waren erst zwei jahre alt aufnahmen der
taten habe der angeklagte zudem ins
internet gestellt
in frankreich ist ein
hochgeschwindigkeitszug tgv bei voller
fahrt entgleist in der nähe von
straßburg wurden dabei 22 menschen
verletzt die meisten passagiere erlitten
prellungen und einen schock
ein erdrutsch hatte die schienen
blockiert der lokführer konnte nur noch
eine notbremsung auslösen und vermutlich
damit schlimmeres verhindern
warum die böschung nach gaap wird jetzt
untersucht und damit jetzt sport hier
bei uns in der heute sendung um 19 uhr
mit biathlon unter besonderen
bedingungen riskieren sonst auch nicht
schön keine zuschauer im stadion vor
einer art geisterkulisse wegen des
corona virus der auftakt des weltcups in
nove mesto tschechien davon zumindest
sportlich unbeeindruckt denise herrmann
die den sprint ohne schießfehler für
sich entschied
eine unwirkliche atmosphäre hier im
stadion von nove mesto die zuschauer
müssen draußen bleiben sind zaungäste
das zweite schießen von denise herrmann
mit einer frühen startnummer im rennen
und wie sie hören hören sie nicht keine
kommentierenden aahs und oohs erneut
fünf treffer wie auch schon beim
liegendanschlag die basis für diesen
souveränen erfolg heute ihr sechster
weltcupsieg die schon cool gewesen zumal
diese stimmung dies sei hier eine ganz
besondere somit sein leben aber es hat
mir jetzt schau die am schießstand nicht
geschadet
auf rang zwei mit einem deutlichen
rückstand anais beeskow moz frankreich
ebenfalls zehn treffer dritter bei ihrem
heim-weltcup die tschechien macht da
wieder war die ihren triumph ohne ihre
fans feiern muss morgen ja sprint der
männer fußball das dfb pokal halbfinale
ist komplett nach dem viertligisten
erster fc saarbrücken und rekordgewinner
bayern münchen sind auch leverkusen und
frankfurt weiter die eintracht verdirbt
durch das 20 bremens hoffnung auf die
ersehnte sportliche trendwende
kurz vor der pause in zügen von
schiedsrichter zwei jahre der video
schiedsrichter hat angefunkt handspiel
von augustin vorn gesehen
zwar entscheidet auf elfmeter silva
verwandelt 1 0 für die eintracht frust
bei werder trainer kufeld wir hatten zu
dem zeitpunkt mit deutlich besser im
spiel hatten zwei chancen der wiesecker
mag sehr gestein wirklich sehr gute
chance haben auch im nach dem 0 1 und
auch nach dem 0 2 140 sehr viel aber
klare chance und deshalb kann
nicht sagen dass das spiel schon
entschieden hat aber es war natürlich
ein großer knackpunkt in der sechzigste
erhöht kamera darauf 2 zu 0 für
frankfurt kostet bekommt der
nachspielzeit rot für ein foul an
bremens top rack der eine risswunde
erleidet frankfurt zum dritten mal seit
2000 17 im halbfinale aber erstmal
bundesliga am samstag in leverkusen
kristin herzlichen dank eine stunde
südlich von kairo steht die älteste
pyramide ägyptens und dass sie da noch
steht ist so sagen experten auch ein
kleines weltwunder
denn die pharaonen grabstätte war selbst
eigentlich schon tot gesagt archäologen
hatten ihren einsturz prophezeit doch
jetzt nach jahrelanger restaurierung
kann die stufenpyramide wieder erkundet
werden
man sollte allerdings wissen wie man
dann auch wieder raus findet denn die
unterirdischen gänge aus dem dritten
jahrtausend vor christus sind ein
einziges labyrinth pur und dann das nach
europa hatte den wärmsten winter seit
beginn der messungen katja horneffer
sagt uns jetzt gleich wie es weitergeht
heute journal mit der kollegin marietta
slomka um 21 uhr 45 danke ihnen allen
für das interesse wenn sie mögen gern
das morgen aber erstmal einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren es
regnet und für manche ist es schon fast
zu viel erreicht dass nicht nur langsam
mit dem regen dazu schauen wir uns die
klimatische wasserbilanz des winters an
sie gibt an wie viel regen gefallen ist
und nicht für die pflanzen verdunsten
und man sieht sie ist durchwegs positiv
ist hat also viel mehr geregnet als die
pflanzen verdutzten im boden den 1 meter
80 tiefe sieht aber anders aus hier in
sachsen zum beispiel gibt es immer noch
regionen in denen es richtig durch ist
also freuen wir uns über den regen der
da kommt und das ist in der nacht eine
ganze menge und in süddeutschland ist
sie regen auch mit schnee vermischt
es gibt dazu starke bis stürmische böen
oder sogar sturmböen über der
schwäbischen alb bruder auch im
schwarzwald die tiefsttemperaturen
sinken heute nacht auf 7 grad am
oberrhein bis 2 grad im allgäu und
morgen steigen die werte dann auf 4 grad
am alpenrand und bis 11 grad in der
lausitz also genau dort wo morgen noch
etwas regen gefehlt
morgen kommt der regen aber dann an und
oberhalb von etwa 700 meter ist auch
schnee dabei tief erledigt morgen mitten
über deutschland es wird recht windig am
samstag ziehen dann die schneeregen und
regenfälle ostwärts ab dann wird es von
westen freundlicher bevor dann am
sonntag von nordwesten schon wieder der
nächste regen heran kommt schönen abend
noch